The second part of the answer to this problem is to do a good job is that as the person
running the random tester--you need to do a pretty good job filtering the bugs that you find
so that you only pass the ones that look important.
The ones that look like there might be critical or security problems or something
onto the developers, and if you find a bunch of bugs that they never see, this isn't a problem.
If you find a bunch of bugs that they're never going to see,
this isn't necessarily a problem but it uses your time.
If you find a bunch of bugs that you never pass on to developers, this isn't necessarily a problem.
You've learned interesting things about the software under test and if you make the decision
to not pass this on then that's probably okay.
It's not uncommon for a simple random tester to spend all its time performing boring tests.
For example, if we do a bad job generating html then maybe all our test
result in rejection by the html cursor and we never find anything interesting.
I have two responses to this kind of thing.
One response is to simply put more resources into the random tester.
For example, we can use more course.
We can use machines with more memory or maybe we can just make random tester faster
by reusing the size of the inputs through a generator.
The other response as we've discussed several times
is to make the random test case generator smarter.
That is to say to use our human expertise or human knowledge of the domain of interest
in order to generate manual test cases that aren't boring.
Random tester may find the same bug many many many times
and if we're going to automatically reject repeated instances of a bug, this isn't a problem.
On the other hand, if we don't have an automated way to do triage of issues that we found,
then this can really waste somebody's time and this issue, we'll talk about explicitly a little bit later.